well ladies and gentleman let's just get
to it sitting in on drums for the second
time this week all right what's it's
great to have you here El Chapo but I
have to ask aren't you supposed to be
facing trial yes but right now I'm
facing the music El Chapo I I have to
say you're not a you're not a good
drummer no no no no I am NOT a drummer
at all which makes this amazing that's
great great el chapo help chapo we got
it we're fine yeah he's you know he's a
bad bad man but I kind of like him you
know yeah I know no I'd meet you he
seems like a nice guy and I oh my god
look El Chapo has tunneled away again
no we should get we shouldn't leave
shovels around yeah ladies back back oh
sorry I just had to go through the
Warner Brothers gift shop
I got a friend's t-shirt and my friends
mug I love friends that's fatal chapo
love friend I know everything about
friends give me any season any episode
number I tell you what the episode is
about alright fine season 3 episode 6
the one where Joey mistakes Ross for a
chicken parmesan sandwich okay oh crap
oh I know friends pretty well I don't
remember that episode at all do you and
yeah that was not a real plot yeah yeah
sorry sorry El Chapo but you are wrong
oh my God look
through the same fake hole that's
ridiculous I just have to go back to the
store and get this the big book of Joey
okay now wait a minute
el chapo you looks like you're getting
emotional about the big book of Joey I
am I love Joey
he was a so stupid yet so loyal he was
like a dog
in fact America friends was called dog
men and the gang that's Frank that's
sexy
by the way in Mexico his name is Matt L
Blanc
terrible that's enough thank you okay
before I go let me tell you one last
thing
so no one told you life was gonna be
this way your jobs a joke you're broke
your love life's DOA I know know that
that's true like you're always stuck in
second gear
oh really hasn't been your day your week
your month or even your year I'll be
there for you
[Applause]
you
you